We use our hands to interact with
objects -- grab them, manipulate them,
and release them. In virtual reality, however,
such fine-grain interaction with virtual
objects is generally not possible.
The main constraint to successfully
render haptics for virtual objects in a
realistic way is that the controller
must be able to produce and endure human
scale forces during interaction and
persist in rendering feedback, especially
when grasping and squeezing objects when
the forces on the controller are the highest.
We present the CapstanCrunch --
the haptic controller that uses
controlled brake technology to render
haptic grasp at varying compliance
levels and that can sustain human scale
grasping forces up to 20 Newtons.
It does so by using capstan-based brake
for variable pure resistive forces and a
clutch cable spring that is capable of
outfitting the stored energy of a built-in spring.
This duality -- capstan break plus clutched spring
-- creates a unique device that can go beyond
limitation of the binary break or a spring and
can simulate human scale forces.
In a simulation of a push button,
the user finger reaches the surface of the
material represented by a brake and
pushes it in against a resistance of a
spring up until some point where the
brake is being released and the user
feels the operation of the click of the
button until the button reaches full brake.
Another example of interaction
implemented with CapstanCrunch is an
assembly of toy construction block.
There are three stages to the assembly.
First, the two blocks are brought
together by bringing the fingers closer.
In stage two, a force is applied to
connect the two blocks together. Once
the blocks are connected the brakes comes
into full stop and then the finger retreats.
Final example of interaction implemented
with CapstanCrunch allows user to cut
materials with the pair of scissors.
The gradual growth of the force due to
increase of the material lever length is
approximated by a set of discrete steps.
We presented CapstanCrunch, a haptic
controller for rendering grasping feedback
up to human scale forces. CapstanCrunch
is built around novel linear adjustable
friction-based capstan brake that renders
human scale forces without the use of large
high-force electrically-powered consumptive
and expensive actuators.